this is the dawning of the age of
Aquarius
this is the new religion that will seek
to subvert Christianity it is the
religion of the water Bearer I remember
reading about this and watching
documentaries back in the day about how
first it was the age of the ram if you
guys have seen Zeitgeist you know what
I'm talking about and that's why the the
Jews would blow the ram horn the Ram's
Horn and then Christianity was the age
of Pisces which is why they use the
symbol of the fish I'm not saying I
think that's true but that's what was
said and then the question was what
would be the the new religion to
supplant and subvert Christianity the
religion of the age of Aquarius well as
we enter the age of Aquarius we have a
new religion in this tweet David Rosado
explains the great awokening is a global
phenomenon no evidence it started in the
U.S media analysis of 98 million news
articles across 36 countries quantifies
exception state-controlled media from
China Russia Iran using wokeness
terminology to criticize and mock the
West
and here we see in this image you can
see the rise of terminologies related to
transphobia homophobia transphobic
islamophobia every one of these
countries even the Congo experienced a
major spike in social justice rhetoric
the one thing that correlates social
media simply put when the AI is created
and shared it functions to serve human
emotion and anger gets the most shares
so treating people like victims to get
them angry got content to be shared The
Human Experience similar all of these
countries started to realize this is
what makes us money the human being who
wrote the article about Trump being
Hitler
did not think they were doing anything
wrong
but what happens is
100 writers each write 100 stories put
them on the Internet and then the
algorithm says yeah the one where Trump
is Hitler that guy gets a million hits
makes a bunch of money and then everyone
says that's what we should write here we
are welcome to the new religion and it's
true because it gets picked up it's kind
of like there's always a language of
power throughout all time there's the
language that everyone kind of speaks
back in the day it was actually it's
like the lingua Franca other you know
the heads of state of England wanting to
speak to the heads of state of Spain if
they couldn't speak Intel intellectually
between English or Spanish they would
use French as the intermediary land was
that at one point nowadays it's speaking
the language of power speaking the
however you want to phrase it wokism
social justices and whatever you want to
call it and that is for example what was
it like Guatemala or something a nation
where to get like twenty thousand
dollars in a state Grant from the US
state department they had to accept I
think some of the money had to be used
for like drag queens shows and in a
country that's more conservative like
Guatemala it's like well why would they
need that it's because if they can speak
the language then the state is going to
in this state meaning the US in this
case will reward them greatly in a
similar way that there used to be actual
fashion crimes remember we kind of joke
about that but that was like a thing you
know the the Nouveau reach of the 1800s
versus the uh like the old money
families and how could they tell each
other apart oh you don't know how to
dress you didn't wear the new fashion
for the spring it sounds kind of silly
right but you see that in today like the
Zuckerberg types they'll kind of dress
down they don't want to be as flashy
with their clothes and stuff because
again it's signaling I'm on a different
level I may be rich you may be rich but
I'm a different level than you so the
money of philanthropy where you can kind
of remake the world in your own image
and you can you kind of use your
Charities like an investment basically
it's not like they're giving away their
money now they're poor it kind of comes
back to help them but again it's
speaking the language of power and as
you were saying Tim earlier like this is
kind of like this has proven to be
successful so this is the language of
power other countries around the world
if they want that U.S money they want
that U.S backing they don't want to
color revolution in their country
they're going to speak that language
even if they're populous is like we
don't want right but they're going to
speak that language and they're going to
push us saying you better speaking such
a profound point and if you have have
ever watched any of the pressers that
come out of the world economic forum and
you see all of the richest people on the
planet and they get up there and they
talk about how they're all concerned
about the poor and I'm like you're not
though you're not but they use that
language it's such that it's such a
great analysis I never even considered
it that that is really the the language
mechanism that traverses language
barriers now because if you're talking
about equity and inclusion well then
you're just one of us other big groups
that have a lot of money a lot back and
go oh that guy I need to get in contact
with him he's in the same wavelength and
the World Bank and the IMF backs the wef
in this entire it's insane new religion
it's the new religion yeah the age of
Aquarius when does it begin
well it depends on who you ask the thing
March 20th 2021 I thought it was 22.50
2160. some people say it begins but it
depends on some people have speculated
they were in it right now or that were
in we're in we're in the cost between I
think you're watching the emergence as
as basically the Catholic church has
done a lot of good in history but it's
also done some bad I think the
pedophilia that came out of that in like
the 90s and stuff annihilated people's
love for Christmas there's a new report
uh I think it was out of Maryland about
a scandal going back to the 60s so all
that stuff is bad and it crushed the old
religion it soured and now people do
need something to believe in it's it's
but this is not what's causing what
we're seeing here it's created The Voice
here's the scary thing
this is you said the dawn of the age of
Aquarius is 2160. this when I pulled it
up it says 2021 so already that we're in
it I had heard in 2012 that it was
coming up in like 21.50 or something it
may be and what is it like every 2 500
years every 22 160 years on 2016. so
think about this at the beginning of the
age it wouldn't immediately be that
everyone is indoctrinated into a new
religion it would be that several
hundred years into that era the new
religion dominates dominates
so this could be as we watch
Christianity start to diminish and this
new psychotic cult take power wow 100
200 years this could be the domination
that is so dark
that's what happens I think perhaps why
so because I'm a devout Catholic I'll
just have to stand up for my church and
say that actually pedophilia obviously
it happens anywhere and everywhere
unfortunately and so actually it was a
lot less that happened in the church
than happens and say the teaching
profession or others the church is
actually has again so it happened on a
smaller scale than people say it just
you know
well the mistake culturally people go oh
the church but on a on a greater thing
um so talking about like the you know
different ages or whatever I think one
thing is what's happened in this nation
has happened uh in a way that has
happened in okay maybe let's rephrase
this so what's happening in our nation
because of some of the market forces
because the liberalism and other things
have eroded the networks that bind
people and make people know who they are
what do you hear today from all the
disaffected mobs the people who will
come up and want to you know scream and
yell and you know threaten you and stuff
these are people who don't know who they
are and you hear that a lot but you go
back 200 years people knew who they were
you know who are you son of John I'm a
farmer on this I'm that they knew who
exactly who they were I'm a Catholic I'm
a presbyterian I'm a this this or that
nowadays people don't know who they are
because people are atomized people are
lonely and so people the again
liberalism Market forces has snipped
Family Ties Community ties religious
ties all the ties That Bind and so
people are lonely they're atomized in
cities they're a lot more easily
emotional they're easier to to lead to
to Riot to do other things because
they're more emotional they don't have a
family that they need to keep their name
good for reputations for because
everyone's kind of on their own so if
you ruin your own name well it doesn't
matter for your brother or someone else
you're kind of all your own individuals
that's something the USSR and other
nations totalitarian states did
purposefully we kind of got here
accidentally that's what I was trying to
say earlier when I forgot my words they
did that intentionally where they had
the state come in and they snipped those
ties they destroyed ethnic groups that
were very strong on religion very strong
on Family Ties they would Deport them
move them you know do whatever and then
again go after church make it
subservient to the state or just shut it
down in general and then on and on
because they're getting people out of
the peasant areas because that's where
tradition usually survives longest and
they were pushing people into the cities
you saw China do this even through like
the 80s and 90s when they were only come
up before they pushed Japan out to
become the world's second largest
economy again and again you saw that
again those totalitarian regimes they
were doing that purposefully because
they don't want they want you listening
to the state first and foremost and not
to your family to your pastor whoever
forgive me but we got here accidentally
but it's the same result I don't agree
it was accidental okay oh well well yeah
okay yeah I get that give me your theory
as to how it happened well I mean it
could be accidental in the sense that
there was just a bunch of policies that
were completely ill-conceived and
moronic maybe or it could be that you
know you you had the war on drugs and
you broke the black family and you
create all sorts of Discord that happens
there
um then you have obviously the
militarism that has persisted throughout
my entire adult life in far longer than
that I think that ultimately those
things alone will kind of unmoor a
society it starts to degrade the culture
the underlying culture the the ties it
behind then you have obviously the uh
the not the Advent but the popularity
that came uh in the atheist movement
over the past 20 years I think was
really interesting and keeping in mind
I'm not a religious person but I think
that it's it's quite evident in
hindsight that there is a a major price
to be paid when you have people that
give up on religion and they make the
state their God and that and that is
what I see being very pervasive amongst
young people I think saying bring up
social media and how that's also
atomizing things is is very true I was
got up this morning pretty early and I
logged onto steam to play some video
games and when I did my dad logged on to
play some video games and I was like my
Dad's here and that we didn't talk
didn't message nothing I just saw his
name and I felt his presence but it
wasn't like I was calling him on the
phone there was no communication
superficial connection I think that's
one of the strange part of our modern
world instead of you're absolutely right
uh going to church seeing your family
living near them being connected in a
really authentic way where you can
communicate with them you know
intimately kind of how they're living
their lives what they're thinking about
what their concerns are you get updates
on social media oh this person got
engaged oh this person's moving houses
and it again we're tuned to have this
dissatisfaction culture where it's like
why am I not getting those things why am
I not in those relationships how can I
solve things who's that fault for that
why don't I have what I want in life I
think part of it is that we don't have a
unifying National culture and we
struggle as a nation because the
geographic size and the complexity of
our makeup to to have that and I think
it became easier to pull people apart
than to bring them together I I think
that the the unifying culture that we
once had was one of you know
bootstrapping it entrepreneurialism I
will find a way through and now
unfortunately because of public
education in my humble opinion you now
have the youngest generation that
believes that they are oppressed
structurally not just because of race
and sexism and all this other stuff but
also because of capitalism they all
believe that capitalism is evil not all
but a huge percentage too I think that
once you have broken that cultural tie
one of like I'm going to find a way to
make it that like that's what the land
of the free the opportunity all this
stuff that's what we used to migrate
here for that's what my great
grandfather came here for and now you
don't hear that talked about very much
from the people that are born here this
is why I think Elon Musk buying Twitter
was so important because I believe that
what we're seeing is just a a i I would
say it's probably more accidental that
when Twitter was created it was the free
speaking of the Free Speech party but
when they Implement these algorithms to
maximize profits they turned a
generation of P people around the world
into psychotic deranged individuals so
so short-sighted though because I mean
yep culturally and and not just
culturally but economically
civilizationally like you're you're
really playing with fire by by feeding
into these algorithmic but no one feels
an obligation to that no one feels like
if you're at the tech entrepreneur and
you could make a billion dollars in a
decade that's what your priorities that
seems like foreign
what happened to his friend see this is
what really bothers me is that story in
SF is sad because here's a guy who was
leaving San Francisco saying the crime
is getting out of control we gotta go
it's his buddies that did this it was
Jack Dorsey Mark Zuckerberg Susan I
pronounce her name these people were
just like we must maximize profits so I
got to be honest the criticism of
capitalism I can get to a certain degree
these big corporations were basically
saying create a social media algorithm
write me code and I wanted to do one
thing
I want it to reduce things that cost us
money and increase things that make us
money and because Big Brand advertisers
are terrified of leftist activists you
were more likely to see if Coca-Cola was
emailed by the far left you're offensive
then they'd be like okay stop that
campaign YouTube Twitter Facebook says
we're losing money what's going on well
the activists are mad but conservatives
wouldn't boycott conservatives don't
protest so these companies have nothing
to worry about even right now with the
Anheuser-Busch boycott you still have a
lot of conservatives being like Oh it's
stupid I don't care okay all right so
Anheuser-Busch is looking at it what
happened Nike doubled down in defense of
Dylan Mulvaney because they do not feel
the economic repercussions from
conservatives I gotta I gotta make the
defense of capitalism argument as an end
cap
um ESG I'm right on this shirt
environmental social governance this is
this is exactly how the government is
dictating diversity Equity inclusion
practices in these businesses in their
marketing schemes like this this is not
an organic thing entirely Tim is
absolutely right the algorithms the
social media world the the youth
movement all that's true but it wouldn't
it wouldn't be this bad you wouldn't
have so many companies that were
insulting their customer base if it
wasn't a financial imperative on the
back end because of BlackRock State
Street Vanguard are functioning under
ESG protocols which dictate that they
will only invest in these companies no
that's true I know but you got it
backwards ESG emerged from this not the
other way around social media companies
like I said Jack Dorsey said we're the
freeze between the Free Speech Free
Speech party so where did ESG come from
yesterday 2005 United Nations so when
these algorithms get implemented this is
the point I made to I can't remember who
we were talking about when it came to uh
academic I think I saw telling Phil
Labonte this as well ESG
and other ideologies how many how many
let me ask you basically how many
ideologies exist right exactly it's
ridiculous there's so many why is it
that only these are prominent today
a vehicle was built by which they could
be pushed onto the masses globally and
it just so happened that what fit those
holes was the likes of ESG correct
there's a bunch of other ideologies that
could have been hey how about white
nationalism oh nope Jack Dorsey banned
that stuff in like 2015-16 they were
like we're getting a lot of flack from
activists we are getting attacked by the
corporate press shut this part down yeah
and then you could not monetize that
content it could not exist and it would
not be influential so nobody went near
it what happens is people like Jack
Dorsey at one point says I'm all about
Free Speech then he has a board and
investors say we're not making money
here and he goes it was it was it was
not an instant thing
that what happened that slowly changed
at Twitter was they would get a bunch of
far left activists who would attack them
and they would say hey look we're
getting attacked a lot for this stuff
people are quitting the far left is much
more likely to boycott protest or quit
than the writers so the economic
pressure is just right there there have
been a bunch of economic ideologies
climate change for instance has not had
as easy of a time as ESG it's funny
right climate change has been around for
a long time with with Al Gore and it's
struggled to get a foothold why because
social media doesn't care there's no
monetary incentive to ban someone who
doesn't care about climate change yeah
but the ESG stuff overlaps with bigotry
homophobia Etc so when someone says
something naughty or racist everybody
says okay whoa whoa whoa hold on there
guys everybody basically agreed we don't
want to see that stuff it gets taken to
an extreme degree the far left throws a
fire bomb and complains and all the
corporations say I don't want to piss
these lunatics off please don't
associate me with those with that kind
of content Twitter then says don't worry
we'll downrank this is literally what
happened YouTube said we will downrank
all of that content so people don't see
it and flag it for demonetization please
please don't leave there was no inverse
pressure from the right to support and
push for things they did like and to
oppose the far left so what happens man
I remember back when they were doing
these weird videos showing kids sex toys
and this is like 2013 2014 it's like
during gamergate that stuff was all
happening conservatives did not have
that as a as a corporate platform
conservatives have have been behind the
the uh behind on this the entire time
simple example act blue and win red the
the Democrats have had an online digital
fundraising platform act blue and it
took the Republicans like three or four
years to figure it out and make their
own that's how far behind they were well
there's two reasons in my estimation one
the conservatives allow the progressives
to raise their children so how do you
happen how are you gonna how are you
going to compete with activism when you
don't have kids that actually share your
values I think you're you're
automatically at a at a dead end thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time